exciting things have been happening in
our solar system there have been reports
recently of a dark spot a bruise that as
they've been calling it on the planet
Jupiter and this was actually discovered
by an amateur astronomer in Australia
there are spots all over this is the
other things going on because it was a
spot also discovered on Venus this is a
white spot rather than a black spot and
astronomers are still arguing about what
might have caused it it's actually very
bright it's sort of a fairly low
southern latitudes in Venus so again was
discovered by an amateur astronomer just
taking some pictures of Venus found
suddenly this big white spot it appeared
anything sort of changing in astronomy
is sort of unusual most of the things we
look at in astronomy you know stars
galaxies and so on they just sit there
I'm changing for billions of years so
it's always interesting when something
new does appear so it's pretty exciting
news
he sent reports out to a few NASA
outlets and just kind of the blogosphere
in general and it started to be picked
up and then some of the major telescopes
in Hawaii and the Hubble Space Telescope
took images of it in the near-infrared
and an optical I knew spots come and go
reasonably regularly on Jupiter so just
having something new appear on Jupiter
isn't that unusual what's unusual about
this is that it's a black spot and as
far as we know the only thing that can
make black spots or something actually
smacking into the planet and so what
they think is that this actually is the
result of an impactor like an asteroid
or a comet that hit Jupiter similar to
the one that happened almost exactly 15
years ago which was comet shoemaker-levy
so we actually watched that one break up
in pieces and slam into Jupiter and the
result was at each point where a piece
slammed into the atmosphere of Jupiter
we could see these really dark spots
resulting from that what's a little
surprising about this one is that no one
was expecting it you know the in the
case of this comet the comet had been
tracked for months and months beforehand
and it was all very well predicted and
people were watching it and expecting it
to happen and this was just a completely
unexpected event and judging from the
size of the of the dent it's made the
size of this black spot that is created
in the clouds it was quite a big object
that smacked into it probably a
kilometer or so in size so it's really
quite a sizable event smashing into into
Jupiter's surface it's I mean it's it
you know there's a bad side and a good
side the bad side is it means there are
lots of things out there that kind of
size just we
you know around the solar system that we
don't know about and in principle one of
them could smash into the earth and
that's you know that really is kind of
you know dinosaur wiping out kind of
size of objects pretty serious from that
point of view the interesting thing is
that one of the things that astronomers
have found during calculations looking
at the structure of the solar system and
modeling the movements of these these
asteroids these small bodies is that
actually Jupiter to an extent protects
us from them that when things come
flying in from the outer solar system
Jupiter they either smash into Jupiter
or Jupiter sort of deflects them away
and so Jupiter acts as something of a
shield protecting us and so it could be
in fact that this object smashing into
Jupiter was an example of Jupiter acting
in this sort of protector or real role
of actually stopping things from getting
into the solar system in a solar system
and potentially doing bad things to the
earth
the other big thing in the solar system
happened on Venus so actually on the
same day news sources were reporting
that there was a bright spot that
occurred on Venus and these it just
looks like a really bright white kind of
elongated structure now such white
features have been seen in the clouds of
Venus before but this is far bigger than
any of that has been detected before
we're not entirely sure astronomers
don't really know how it was created
so it's possible one theory is that
there was a volcano on the surface that
sent up a lot of material into the upper
atmosphere so if that sulfur dioxide
there's a lot of that and Venus reacted
with the water vapor and the upper
atmosphere then it can form sulfuric
acid things like that which become
really reflective of the sun's light so
it just increases its brightness and we
can identify it that way that one again
it was another amateur astronomer who
discovered it and then reported it to
various news sources and and astronomy
organizations
oh we get very excited so with the
because I mean by the wonders of the
Internet basically as soon as these
things are discovered the entire world
knows about them and so as soon as we
learn about them we can go actually go
out there and follow up with much bigger
telescopes and get much more detailed
more detailed pictures of them and so
for example that's a new camera just
being installed on the Hubble Space
Telescope which is an actually even
commissioned yet it's not even actually
supposed to be doing taking data yet but
as but when this event came up they got
so excited about it that they actually
went and took some pictures with it and
of the the big black spot on Jupiter the
new black spot on
Jupiter and were able to kind of get
some very high-quality pictures of it
it's good that professional astronomers
have big telescopes that can look out to
very specific places but it's also
really nice to have a lot of smaller
telescopes smaller eyes looking at
various places as often as they can the
discoveries like this for were like this
the stuff that amateur astronomers do is
absolutely invariant valuable just
because there is just so much out there
in space and there's only maybe what
10,000 professional astronomers in the
world so there's no way we can be
looking at it all I'm glad that it's a
science we're not only professional
people but also amateurs can contribute
as well because they're contributing
great things to our general knowledge
which is ultimately what we want whether
or not you do it as a job or a hobby
let's figure out how the universe works